on va enchaîner avec le débat qui
concerne aujourd'hui l'accueil des
migrants on apprend cette semaine donc
un hôtel situé à Menton un hôtel Ibis
près de la frontière franco-italienne
aurait reçu un avis de réquisition de la
préfecture pour accueillir 50 mineurs
étrangers isolés des Lindi le directeur
de l'hôtel est en colère et c'est pas
comment gérer la situation on regarde le
sujet et Éric nollo va venir nous
rejoindre également pour donner son avis
sur le sujet à vous on vous demande
comprenez-vous la colère du directeur de
l'établissement oui non c'est parti
menton se prépare à faire face à cet
afflux les gérants de cet hôtel ont reçu
un avis de réquisition potentielle de
l'établissement pour accueillir 50
mineurs isolés si jamais ce cas devait
se produire on devra tout simplement
inviter nos clients actuellement à
l'hôtel à partir pour un autre
établissement ce qui est pas une chose
facile puisque nous on a une clientèle
fortement internationale du côté des
habitants c'est un mélange d'empathie et
de ralbol qui domine alors les habitants
sont vraiment contre on l'a vu euh avec
de nombreux témoignages Éric nollo merci
d'être là euh comprenez-vous la colère
du directeur euh alors euh yenade vous
vous dites oui euh oui oui oui parce que
c'est compliqué de pas comprendre la
colère de quelqu'un déjà je veux
préciser que c'est l'honneur de la
France he d'accueillir sur son sol des
gens qui fui la guerre des demandeurs
d'asile on l'a fait en Afghanistan on
l'a fait aussi en Ukraine moi ce qui me
choque c'est un peu la viis de
réquisition euh envoyé par un simple
mail je trouve qu'il y a un manque
peut-être d'accompagnement de la part de
la préfecture après j'ai peut-être pas
tous les infos peut-être qu'il y a des
gens qui viennent qui viennent les aider
les conseiller mais c'est plus la qui me
choque je souscris tout ce alors Valérie
benim je souscris à tout ce que vient de
dire yenade c'estàd qu'effectivement on
ne peut pas ne pas avoir de l'empathie
pour tous ces jeunes mineurs isolés qui
se retrouvent comme ça ils sont au
nombre de 50 et et dont on ne sait pas
quoi faire apparemment toutes les
solutions alternatives ben ils sont
blindé de partout il ils savent pas où
les mettre donc ordre de réquisition et
moi je comprends le désarroi de ce ce
patron d'hôtel qui se dit je je ne suis
pas armé c'est pas mon métier je ne sais
pas faire donc voilà alors pour
l'instant ils disent que c'est peutêtre
c'est V la dernière soltion ouais ouais
c'est toujours la dernière solution avec
no moi je la comprends quatre fois je la
comprends parce queil y a une brutalité
de la décision qui est incroyable
réquisition c'est pas la peine de
développer une réquisition c'est très
très brutal deuxièmement on demande à
cet homme de compenser la nullité des
pouvoirs publics nous sommes incapables
de faire pression sur les pays d'origine
pour qu'ils empêchent les départs
illégaux nous sommes incapables de
contrôler nos frontières bon ensuite il
y a des choses un peu plus fâcheuses je
vais entrer dans le vif du sujet les
mineurs isolés quand on fait des
contrôles quand on fait des tests il
s'avère que 75 % des mineurs isolés ne
sont ni mineurs ni isolés donc il y a
quand même il y a quand même quelque
chose qui qui ne va pas et ensuite
comment vous voulez expliquer à un
Français moyen qu'il y a en France des
centaines peut-être des milliers de
personnes qui dorment dans la rue et
auquels on ne peut rien proposer et tout
d'un coup il y a des migrants qui
arrivent et là tout d'un coup on trouve
vous les loger comment vous voulez faire
entendre ça à un Français moyen parce
que ce sont des mineurs bout c'est c'est
un détail qui qui a tout son
importancecoup de mineurs qui dor dans
la rue aussi 2000 enfants qui dor dans
la rue en France il y a 2000 enfants qui
dorment dans la rue il a raison non mais
je vous le dis faudrait peut-être
trouver des log on en fait quoi alors de
ces jeunes non mais c'est il va être
payé ce monsieur il va ses chambres
elles vont être occupées il va être
rémunéré en fait en fait moi je me dis
juste je veux bien comprendre que ça
soit difficile de de d'accepter ce genre
de situations mais en même temps c'est
un geste humain qui n'a pas de prix
enfin là on parle on sait pas où les
mettre où les mettre par d'ê humain on
parle de ça pourrait être nos enfants ça
pour si t appartement il est
réquisitionné tuacceptes si on me paye
bien
évidemment bien évidemment pourquoi je
dir non non si on dit on me dit il y a
deux enfants de 10 ans qui viennent dans
ton appartement et on te paye un
loyer faut arrêter de prendre le
problème dans le mauvais sens c'est pas
à l'arrivée qu'on juge le problème c'est
au départ que font ces gamins en France
comment se fait-il qu'ils ont réussi
s'ils sont vraiment des mineurs isolés
comment se fait-il qu'un mineur isolé a
réussi à quitter son pays à franchir
illégalement
des quand un être humain est proche de
collapse et ben il fuit son pays vous
savez très bien qu' des filières
organisé pour les faire on était
africain si on vivait dans des pays en
guerre on aurait envie de se
Barr tous les mêmes les êtres humain
sont tous les mêmes Hugo d'abord la
plupart ne sont pas issu de pays en
guerre on l'a vu là avec les arrivées à
Lampedusa donc ça person c'est pas on le
sait a été établi ça a été documenté
donc on sait que c'est ça peut pas être
un argument moi ce que je trouve
absolument effarant dans cette affaire
c'est que ça fait partie des top de ou
trois des préoccupations de tous les
pays européens on sait qu'il va y avoir
des migrations de plus en plus fortes du
Sud vers le Nord pour des questions de
de de de social pour des questions de
niveau de vie enfin pour plein de
questions qui sont légitimes hein c'est
pas du tout ce que je dis et on n'est
absolument pas organisé pour ça on n'est
pas organisé pour les accueillir alors
oui en plus il y a un problème c'est que
au départ il y a des on sait maintenant
que le prix de la traversée c'est 700 ou
800 € ça a été ça a été documenté là
aussi à l'ampedusa on sait qu'il y a
tout un trafic et on sait que on a donné
de l'argent on a déversé des millions
d'euros à un certain nombre de pays
notamment la Tunisie ça n'a pas
fonctionné ça fonctionne pas donc là il
faut que les pays européens
s'organisent pour les accillir qu'
soganis moi je pense au vie humaine en
fait moment soyez lucide soyez lucide ce
que vous encouragez là c'est le traf d'ê
hum j'encourage le message que vous
envoyez au prochain passeurs c'est
d'envoyer encore plus de gamins de de de
d'empocher encore plus d'argent parce
que à l'arrivée on va régler le problème
en réquisitionnant des hôtels les
passeurs ils sont pas fous ils disent
comment ça se passe en France ah bah ça
se passe très bien les gens sont pas
renvoyés ils restent sur place donc ils
vont avoir de plus en plus de candidats
à ses traversés vous les encouragez avec
du tout moi ce que j'encourage c'est
juste un peu d'humanité et ne me faites
pas rire en disant vous les
accueilleriez chez vous parce que c'est
pas vrai
qu'est-ce que vous en savez là on leur
demande pas on réquisitionne pas les
chambres d'hôtel gratuitement une farce
mais c'est une farce de quoi vous
connaissez pas du
tout chez vous parce que si vous êtes
payé si mon appartement n'est pas occupé
si mon appartement n'est pas occupé bien
évidemment si c'est comme un hôtel le
même principe
qu'ô exactement voilà ce ce que vient de
dire Géraldine ça c'est très intelligent
parce que actuellement l'hôtel il est
quasiment plein des clients il do ils
doivent sortir les clients et les mettre
ailleurs donc cet Helier il a droiter
cel
mais moi j'en ai marre quand même malgré
tout s de bienveillance de Dr de l'homme
de l'humanité des plateau télé pas
encore reçu j'ai pas encore j'ai pas
encore pris Gill Verdes il va tuer mais
non non je veux que tu fasses non non
non mais moi je tuer personne en fait
évidemment on est tous consternés
évidemment que c'est horrible évidemment
que c'est des drames humains évidemment
qu'il y a des gens qui meurent en
Méditerranée évidemment que c'est
insupportable mais la situation de ce
pauvre hôtelier elle est aussi
insupportable il est aussi victime ben
je le mets dans malgré tout on lui prend
sa vie en fait on lui dit oui mon ça va
durer combien de temps mais peu importe
on sa pas Dansel état il va retrouver
son hôtel on sa pas s va y avir des
dégradation ple
Degrad traverser la Méditerranée pour
survivre c'est le même niveau qu'un
Helier attends ok vous vous êtes
formidable parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'humanité contrairement à nous qui
avons dit oui qui sont d'ignoble
personnage je trouve juste que malgré
tout il y a évidemment éc no l'a dit
alors on veut pas l'entendre on se
bouche le nez parce qu'on a pas envie de
l'entendre mais on est obligé face au
laxisme et face à la lâcheté de nous
gouvernant on est obligé d'utiliser un
pauvre monsieur qui est Helier qui a un
hôtel il se régale c'est c'est sa
passion il y a plein de clients et
aujourd'hui on lui dit bah merci
monsieur vous pouvez plus exercer votre
métier vous dégagez vos clients et vous
mettez des mineurs isolé excuse-moi
c'est inaudible en fait ça n'est pas
possible solution tu proposes quelle
solution toi pour tous ces jeuneses
enfants mais peu importe en fait desen
fous il y a pas tu cherches pas de
solution pour les enfants tant pis pour
eux pas des
Français s'en fout du coup comme c'est
pas des Français c'est des sous pas des
S camp des des choses comme ça mais mais
pas pas réquisitionn je et solution et
ben des établissements il a a des
établissements publics il et ben ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il y a bien un
problème en
fait prend les chez toi oh c'est bon
Jean-Michel mer estce que tu es
volontaire Jean-Michel non mais on est
d'accord que c'est un drame humain mais
de toute façon on règle jamais les les
problématiques au son de l'émotion
l'émotion ça doit se mettre
malheureusement un peu de côté mais les
question d'immigrants c'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que ça arrive ça fait des
des pratiquement 10 ans qu'il y a des
migrants à calé et cetera on n pas eu le
temps de construire des centres
d'accueil et cetera on est obligé de
réquisitionner les hôtels c'est
malheureusement un constate d'échec du
gouvernement qui n'a pas su prévoir
voilà donc c'est pas au hôteliers de de
morfler à la
place qu mainten suite des événements ça
va être quoi les gamins parce qu'on l'a
vu par le passé vont tous se tirer de
l'hôtel vont disparaître dans la nature
et ensuite vous allez les retrouver
d'ici quelques semaines soit sous le
métro aérien de Paris soit en bordure du
périphérique ben écoutez Prz le méro
ch
AR sur méro la place du taxi arrte
arrête arrête arrête arr quand prenez le
métro aérien vous voyez tous les
migrants qui se retrouvent là quand vous
prenez le périphérique tax prend
peut-être le périphérique quand il vous
transporte vous voyez les camp de
migrants en bordeur du périphérique ne
niz pas la réalité c'est ça la réité et
soit malheureusement on les retrouve
dans des fêes divers et ça c'est un peu
compliquéés je suis
désoléisésol oncoute là tu es en train
de nous dire immigration fa divers je pe
pasrire à çaésol parfois c'est le
cas chose il y a il y a le problème de
base pourquoi continuer à prendre des
migrants alors que on n'arrive pas à les
intégrer et à les insérer notre pays il
a déjà assez de problèmes pour insérer
tout le monde qui est déjà dans le pays
donc c'est très compliqué de prendre des
gens et après effectivement ils iront
dans la nature voilà ensuite le monsieur
qui qui paye ses traites depuis des
années pour s'acheter quand même son
bien privé qui est un hôtel à des fins
commerciales pourquoi est-ce on le
réquisitionne déjà on lui demande même
pas sa permission c'est quand même un
lieu commercial un lieu avec du public
donc ça risque peut-être aussi de gêner
le reste de la clientèle s il y a des
dégâts dans les on sa pas mais tu
parles des dégâts on ne sait pas les
gens qui font du Airbnb savent très bien
qu'avec des gens très très bien on a des
dégâts moi la première à le savoir donc
je suis désolé peut-être que ce mec il
va avoir des chambres qui vont être un
peu voilà
abîméa PL bon et en plus de ça le droite
de parler non non mais c'est bon la dans
la rue et dans le quartier est-ce que ça
va pas aussi
peut-être déranger peut-être la
tranquillité du quartier c'est une
question que je pose alors alors les
gens sont extrêmement hostile à leur
arrivé c'est ce qu'on a vu en Pascal
sont partagés pourquoi ils sont pas
reconduits par pour gens sont
particulièrement hostile à l'arrivée
pour la PL
peur des micro trottoir où les gens
disai sur l'affaire des migrants isolés
je voudrais juste dire une chose c'est
qu'il y a aussi un autre problème c'est
que parfois on a beaucoup de mal à
savoir si ce sont vraiment des mineurs
isolés c'estàd qu'ils arrivent souvent
sans papier d'identité
SAF que quand on vérifie on s'eroit
qu'il sont pas murs
tour même une ttique des en plusur le
problème c'est que
c'estur pas eux qui que j'incrimine mais
ce sont les passeur a du trafic c'est du
trafic humain des gens qui se font de
l'argent sur des sur
des cherchez aucuneimession qu'on parle
même pas d'êtes humain vous cherchez
aucune solutionine tu dis on va chercher
comme si on allait les chercher ces
migrants ils arrivent pour fuir pour
sauver leur vie c'est que n'importe
lequel d'entre nous dans dans nos cœurs
si on est dans un pays où on sait qu'on
va crever qu'est-ce qu'on va faire c'est
un instinct de survie comme une gazelle
qui fuit et ben on va fuire on va
essayer d'aller là où on a un avenir
donc je suis pas en train de dire qu'il
faut accueillir toute la misère du monde
je suis bien d'accord que l'État est
très mal organisé je suis pas en train
de dire ça je juste en train de dire que
quand je vous écoute tous je trouve que
on dirait que vous ne parlez pas d'être
humains et c'est ça qui désoleelle fait
la gr
ch je suis pas la GR je pay euréens
dégag en fait on pe
concr mais tu opposes ton immense
humanité comme si nous on était iNum
comme si on était méchant
CR c'est la solution de facilité de dire
non
mais c'est la solution de facilité qui
consiste à dire non mais c'est pas
possible il faut avoir le cœur sur la
main il s'agit d'êt humain mais on est
tous d'accord avec ça en fait on est
tous d'accord on veut juste expliquer
une chose c'est que c'est un trafic qui
est organisé les passeurs c'est c'est
ils sont très peu condamnés très peu
poursuivis on est en retard et ça va
continuer et ça va empirer parce que
effectivement il y a le réchauffement
climatique parce que il y a la misère du
monde parce qu'on est des pays riches et
que eux sont quand même dans des
situations qui sont bien moins
confortables donc ils vont continuer et
on est totalement désorganisé c'est pas
un hôtelier de régler ça comme ce sera
pas demain un directeur de camping et
Cera et ca % des Français opposés à
l'avenue des migrants depuis l'Italie un
dernier sondage j'ajoute une chose il y
a une dimension que ne connais pas Gill
Verdes qui s'appelle la réal j'ai rien
dit encore dans la réalité dans la
réalité que vous fréquenterez peut-être
un jour ça nous fera des vacances
figurez-vous que ces gamins lâchés dans
la nature pour survivre pour nombre
d'entre eux pas tous il se livrent à des
actes de délinquence justement
mettonsles à l'ôtel ils seront mieux
dans ils vont pas y rester ils vont pas
y rester vont pas rester donc dans
certains quartiers de Paris allez allez
aussi il y a des il y a une autre
dimension vous ne connaissez pas ça
s'appelle les gens dans la vraie vie
parlez avec les gens de certains
quartiers parle avec les gens de
certains quartier et demandez-leur si la
délinquence n'est pas d en partie à
certains de ces mineurs isolés parle
avec des flics ils vont vous expliquer
ils vont vous sortir des statistiques
seulement vous ne voulez pas parler de
la réalité ni vous pour vous vous êtes
dans une dimension irréelle où tout le
monde doit entrer et mon Dieu
accueillonsles tous et ça ça va bien se
passer ça se passe mal ça se passe mal
non mais on est en train de délirer moi
je dis bravo au préfet qui a pris cet
acte de réquisition et je ne comprends
pas la colère de l'hôtelier le
département des Alpes Maritimes est
submergé c'est le président du
département qui a dit au préfet
aidez-moi réquisitionnons on a des
dizaines de mineurs isolés qui sont des
gens vulnérables qui peuvent être
attaqués violés assassinés batttu mais
laissez-moi finir donc du coup Cyr c'est
un acte nécessaire c'est même pas de
l'humanité c'est un un acte légal et AB
absolument indispensable de les accueir
dans un hôtel dont il ne fuit pas c'est
là où ils peuvent s'installer qu'on peut
faire des recherches d'où ils viennent
qu'est-ce qu'on va en faire on peut pas
les laisser à la rue donc ce préfet ce
préfet devrait êt imiter par des tas
d'autres départements il doit y avoir
des lieux où ces mineurs isolé doivent
être reçus pris en charge et même pas de
l'humanité c'est pour le bien-être
public est-ce que vous pouvez voir plus
loin que le bout de votre nez qu'est-ce
que oui justement justement ça déjà loin
vous propose les prochains 10000 on va
les accueillir les prochains 100000 on
va on va
réquisitionner mineurs isolés mais tous
les mineurs
isolés pas la
àagiss plus de place dans les établisss
public préur les G qui ont hôtels privés
avec leur travail par ailleurs on peut
se poser la question de savoir si
vraiment la France est en mesure et en
capacité d'accueillir des diaines
mais ils sont là les mineurs isolés ils
sont dans la rue dans les Alpes
Maritimes la Grèce a réussi à limiter
les
arrivées50 % de 50 % quand un pays le
veut vraiment si l'Europe voulait
vraiment aujourd'hui plutôt que de dire
mon dieu c'est terrible ce qui nous
arrive de Contin continuer de le dire
pendant 10 20 30 40 ans et bien ça ça va
pas ça su alors je vis parler un petit
peu chiffre parce que qui va payer bien
sûr la d'El c'est la question que vous
posez certainement euh chez vous c'est
le budget du département des Alpes
maritimes qui finance c'est bon c'est
bon euh sont des sommes très élevées euh
qui sont en jeu en 2023 le département
annonce qu'il va consacrer 28 millions
d'euros à la prise en charge des mineurs
non accompagnés c'est 3 37 fois plus
qu'il y a 7 ans je reviens sur ce que
disait Éric nollo là Éric tu vas
rebondir forcément tu vas dire pourquoi
cet argent on arrive à le trouver mais
là les sommes que vous mentionnez cyil
c'est rien par rapport à ce que ça va
être donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait on dit
non tout va bien que ça continue comme
ça c'est 28 millions aujourd'hui sera ce
sera 56 millions demain et cetera et
cetera non mais si on veut pas réfléchir
on se contente de réagir comme Verdez et
de jamais réfléchir c'est confortable
mais ça ne mène pas loin c'est de la
politique à courte vue il faut
simplement agir sur les causes du
problème donc empêcher ces gens de
partir de chez eux parce que c'est
illégal c'est la responsabilité des
gouvernements et nous reprendre le
contrôle de nos frontières un pays qui
ne contrôle pas ses frontières ne
contrôle rien il a perdu sa
souveré alors g tu sais bien que quand
on a un budget on doit définir des
priorités est-ce que tu aimerais pas
quand même pour le bien de la France que
ces 28 millions il soit donné par
exemple à l'hôpital français mais je
suis très content que ces 28 millions
c'est l'honneur des Alpes Maritime soit
consacré à ces mineurs isolés mais vous
rendez pas compte ce que vous dites il y
a pas de priorité entre la vie de
mineurs isolés et des gens à l'hôpital
Budet
national ça doit être pour le national
parce qu'on parce que parce national ils
sont dans les rues des Alpes Maritimes
ce n'est pas national malheureusement
non là non mais non mais non mais non
mais c'est bon euh mooun moi en fait je
suis assez d'accord avec Hugo je
comprends que effectivement le
gouvernement il soit pas bien organisé
qu' ait plein de choses à revoir ça tout
ça d'accord après quand j'entends des
énormités désolé mais quand tu dis euh
ça pose problème aux gens qui habitent
dans le quartier parce que ça va poser
des non ben ils sont regarde 65 % mais
je suis 65 % des Français sont contre et
dans le et dans le dans les dans là dans
des ALP maritime ré 0% voilàé versus PL
télé non bouche le nez voilà VO ça
on peut pas se dire qu'en gros le
problème c'est que on va avoir des
migrants en bas de chez nous je veux
dire ça veut dire qu'en gros oui c'est
ça l'idée c'est que on on les repousse
dans l'eau et on leur dit bah rentrez
chez vous mais n'importe quoi et il y a
il y a le truc que j'ai lu c'est que en
principe de le principe de non
discrimination prévue par la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant il
bénéficie des mêmes droits que des
enfants français et je vois pas pourquoi
si on si on on fout pas dehors tous les
enfants français pourquoi eux ils
auraient pas le droit d'y aller le mec
il est payé son hôtel il va être plein
je veux dire c'est pas plus une
aberration que de dire que ces gens-là
ils sont pas dehors non mais les valeurs
humanistes elles se heurent toujours un
moment à la réalité à ta propre réalité
toi du coup tu es pas tu ne sis pas
concernés par les problèmes des migrants
maisas une valeur humaniste c'est bien
c'est louable sauf que moi par exemple
toi j'ai j'ai toujours essayé d'aider
les SDF et ceter et il y a quelques
années à côté de chez moi ils ont créé
un centre d'hébergement pour SDF et ben
j'étais à deux doigts de créer parce
qu'il y avait une pétition qui cétait
créée pour les faire sortir parce que
c'était insupportable la vie était venue
terrible pour les habitants du qui
étaient proche de centre d'hébergement
alors on était pour qu' qu'on les
héberge on sort de la rue mais pas à
côté de chez nous et voilà parce que
c'était des nuisances terribles je
trouve qu'il y a pire c'est que quand
j'entends les humanistes du camp d'en
face là vous avez l'impression de faire
le bien de ses enfants alors que vous
allez faire leur malheur mal GAM G qui
vont se retrouver dans la nature ils
vont être utilisés par les délinquants
qui sont déjà sur place pour leur sale
besogne parce que ils vont les obliger à
cambrioler à se prostituer d'ailleurs
comme ils sont mineurs ils vont passer à
travers non mais à travers les gouttes
ensuite en effet moi j' dans un quartier
où je les vois où je vois ce que donne
cette immigration incontrôlée ça donne
des gens qui ont le choix entre se faire
exploiter par les délinquant ou devenir
délinquants eux-mêmes c'est ça l'avenir
que vous leur proposez sous un discours
humaniste vous êtes en plein égarement
vous êtes en plein déni de réalité y a
du vrai non il y a du vrai dans dans ce
que vous dites mais vous ne proposez
aucune solution c'est-àdire que nous on
n' pas avec G ENF en tout cas pour ma
part je ne souhaite pas que que des gens
viennent de façon illégale en France ce
n'est pas mon souhait mais tu les
encourages une
FO de me projeter et de me dire que
humainement pour se sauver ils font ça
et que nous on est bien obligé de
trouver des
solution vous envoyez le
message
futur quand on arrive en France et bien
on va être logé à l'hôtel et que ça va
très très
bien pas du tout c'est ce que vont leur
dire les pasteursurs regardez comment ça
se passe en
franceé est-ce que vous est-ce que tu ne
crois pas Hugo que ces gens savent ce
qui se passe en Europe lorsque les
immigrés arrivent si on renvoie le
signal systématiquement qu'ils arrivent
qu'il y a pas de problème que des
enfants soitdisant mineurs isolés qui en
fait ne le sont pas vont être finalement
accueillis et bien qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ça va continuer est-ce que la
France est en capacit méitrané mais bien
et c'est terrible et c'est terrible tu
crois que quand tu sais que tu vas
potentiellement mourir tu poses la
question tu te dis ah ça a l'air cool en
Europe hyper facile je vais je vais y
aller si tu es prêt à mourir dans la mer
méditerran au nom de ça il faut tout
accepter vie elle a
pu au nom de l'humanisme il faut tout
accep réfléchissez un
peuupportable concl mais vous délirez
complètement là vous êtes en train de
dire d'abord d'abord vous présupposez
com nolo et Jacques que ces mineurs pour
la plupart ne sont pas mineurs vous n'en
savez
rien c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
ensuite non mais vous dites on devrait
pas pe pas protester des
chiffres
m isol C excusez-moi il y a des
vérifications au bout de quelques
semaines on sait s'il sont des mineurs
ou
[Musique]
pas pe être d'accord avec toi ou pas
d'accord mais ne remet pas en cause des
chiffres qui sont sont qui sont factuels
arrête de dire des B exement le même
problème que les P pocket dans le métro
ils disent tous que c'est gens de voyage
ou aut qui disent qu'ils sont mineurs ça
il savent
qu' 9% d'hommes on a dit ah il y a des
femmes et des enfants 90% d'hommes sont
les
chiffresêes trou
solutions vous êtes les compli
intellectuels des
[Applaudissements]
passeursmichiss tranquille les gens du
voyage bien
s
TR mais les met dans une CHU dans
laquelle ils sont pas du
tout bon allez merci en tout cas g VO
exement merci allez on y va merci
d'avoir été là